Calculul cuantic a intrat în era utilității
ceea ce înseamnă că putem începe să folosim calculatoarele cuantice pentru a rezolva
probleme din lumea reală, inclusiv unele care sunt foarte dificile
pentru calculatoarele clasice
o temă comună în era actuală
este că o problemă este rezolvată
pentru prima dată pe un calculator cuantic
și apoi lumea găsește o modalitate de a o face pe un calculator clasic
acest ciclu al calculului clasic
și cuantic care se împing reciproc spre
limite va continua probabil
câțiva ani există clase de probleme unde calculul cuantic
poate avea un avantaj demonstrabil
față de calculul clasic
date fiind progresele în domenii precum
reducerea erorilor și numărul de qubit-uri disponibile
există și domenii întregi de aplicații
unde calculul cuantic
ar putea fi util în viitorul relativ apropiat
unul dintre aceste domenii este machine learning-ul cuantic sau QML
machine learning-ul cuantic se referă la
aplicarea calculului cuantic în orice tip de proces de
machine learning există desigur
multe tipuri de machine learning
două tipuri de interes deosebit sunt
învățarea supervizată în care
antrenezi un algoritm folosind un set de date etichetat
și învățarea nesupervizată în care
algoritmul lucrează cu mostre neetichetate
și încearcă să învețe despre distribuție
sau despre funcția care o generează
un algoritm nesupervizat ar putea
de exemplu să învețe cum să genereze mostre noi
din aceeași distribuție sau cum să
grupeze mostrele în clustere cu caracteristici similare
atât învățarea supervizată cât și cea nesupervizată implică adesea
înglobarea datelor în spații de dimensiuni mai mari
iar manipularea datelor în spații de dimensiuni mai mari
ar trebui să ne facă să ne gândim la calculul cuantic
lasă-mă să explic imaginează-ți că încerci să rezolvi problema dacă
să clasifici un punct de date din plan
ca un cerc sau o cruce pe baza datelor de antrenament etichetate de aici
uneori datele pot fi clar separate de o linie
sau un plan în dimensiuni mici
cum se arată aici și clasificarea acestor puncte de date
în cele de deasupra liniei
și cele de sub linie ar trebui să fie
o nimica toată dar uită-te la această distribuție
clar nu există nicio linie vizibilă care să separe punctele de date
totuși pentru aceste date ne-am putea imagina un fel de
mapare din două dimensiuni în trei dimensiuni
astfel încât după aplicarea mapării datele noastre arată
ca ăsta și există clar un plan care separă cele două
clase pe care îl putem folosi
pentru clasificare dacă acest tratament pare un pic simplist
ai dreptate nu putem pune pur și simplu punctele de date pe care le vrem
mai sus fără nicio justificare
trebuie să existe o mapare
de la distribuția 2D care să separe eficient
punctele noastre de date astfel încât să putem
folosi maparea pentru a clasifica noi puncte de date
asta va fi discutat mai pe larg în lecția care face o recapitulare de
machine learning dar e suficient să spunem
că problema poate fi privită
ca încercarea mai multor mapări diferite în acest spațiu de dimensiuni mai mari
pentru a vedea care mapări produc cea mai bună
separare a punctelor de date din clase diferite
această manipulare a datelor în dimensiuni mai mari
este un domeniu în care calculul cuantic
poate avea un impact mare pentru a înțelege de ce
să revenim la diferențele dintre calculul clasic
și cel cuantic la fel
cum calculatoarele clasice folosesc biți de informație
calculatoarele cuantice folosesc qubit-uri
dar pentru un număr dat de biți să zicem patru
un calculator clasic poate lua oricare dintre
cele două la puterea patru sau șaisprezece stări posibile
un calculator cuantic poate accesa și el șaisprezece stări posibile
dar poate exista într-o superpoziție a tuturor
celor șaisprezece stări simultan
și operațiile pot fi efectuate asupra acestei superpoziții întregi
pentru patru qubit-uri asta poate să nu pară
mare lucru dar imaginează-ți ce s-ar putea face cu
un calculator cuantic în două la puterea douăzeci sau
două la puterea o sută douăzeci și șapte
stări simultan există multe alte diferențe
între calculul clasic și cel cuantic care vor
juca toate un rol în acest subiect
stările cuantice au amplitudini de probabilitate complexe
manipulările sistemelor cuantice sunt efectuate cu
operatori unitari iar calculatoarele cuantice sunt supuse unor tipuri diferite
de zgomot față de calculatoarele clasice
aceste diferențe vor apărea
pe parcursul activității tale de machine learning cuantic în domenii
precum codificarea datelor, feature mapping și atenuarea erorilor
în unele cazuri aceste diferențe dintre calculul clasic
și cel cuantic ne permit să proiectăm
algoritmi complet noi acum aceea a fost o privire de ansamblu foarte scurtă
asupra unirii a două domenii extrem de complexe
dar sperăm că două lucruri sunt clare
machine learning-ul rezolvă adesea probleme
prin manipularea datelor în dimensiuni foarte mari
și în al doilea rând calculatoarele cuantice sunt bine adaptate
pentru a manipula date în dimensiuni mari
și o fac diferit față de sistemele clasice
asta ar trebui să îți dea o idee
despre de ce machine learning-ul este un domeniu promițător
pentru aplicarea calculului cuantic util